let's go to Tristan from Washington
Tristan from Washington welcome to the
program what is on your mind today
Tristan from Washington I've invited you
to join me on the program you do need to
accept it in order to be able to talk to
me
Tristan welcome
I
hello hi can you hear me
yes you're cutting in and out but we are
connected which is a good start
that's strange I don't know what the
issue is
um
hi it's good to speak to you again
um I was just wondering like what is
your
what is your view on the Republicans
choosing Sarah Huckabee Sanders to make
the response to the State of the Union
last night
couple thoughts
um and that was on uh on Tuesday of
course you know Arkansas as a state is a
disaster and that's not me using ad
hominems it's just on education on
income on crime on it Healthcare it's
just a disastrous State they have a lot
of real problems and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders has wasted time as Governor
doing things like Banning the teaching
of critical race Theory which isn't
actually being taught so she is quite
frankly an embarrassment but the reason
Republicans may choose her is because
they see her as the prototypical
Republican going forward which is she is
definitely savvier and less cartoonish
than people like Marjorie Taylor green
and Lauren bobert and she's potentially
part of a generation that the Republican
Party sees as being the types of folks
that maybe in 10 years could be
presidential candidates so I think that
that she was chosen because she is seen
by Republican party insiders as exactly
the direction that Republicans should be
going now that's scary but I think that
that's how they see it
yeah no I was gonna I was gonna ask you
about why they didn't chose choose
somebody like Marjorie Taylor green
because it just seemed it seemed like
maybe maybe she is more cartoonish but
it seems like people like her and Lauren
bobert are more a little more relevant
than Sarah Huckabee Sanders I don't know
the data of how many people have
actually heard of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
are what what she's done but it makes
sense to me it listen I think that
Republican I think that the RNC realizes
that people like bobert and green are
widely seen as jokes to the greater
country whereas an Arkansas governor is
sort of a different story there's a that
she seems slightly more serious
yeah yeah
um that makes sense and one other uh
comma question that I have
it's about you know term limits you had
brought this up on one of your recent
bonus shows
I personally as somebody on the left
I don't really see
the benefit to imposing term limits on
Congress like I I and I think one of the
reasons
that I say that is because it seems to
me
that we're going to have the same
problems no matter who's in office
it just doesn't seem like it
I I seems to me like things like
campaign Finance reform could be the
most immediate concern well as I've said
before Tristan we need I'm in favor of
term limits but term limits alone won't
fix the problems we have I believe we
need term limits combined with campaign
Finance reform combined with for
presidential elections going to a
national popular vote combined with
going to some version of single
transferable vote for all elections
that's a lot of stuff but I do see term
limits as one piece of Reform that I
would like to see
yeah no I I'm just against term limits
altogether I I don't see them as being
super valuable I don't I'm actually even
against term limits for president like I
think that constitutional amendment was
kind of ridiculous wow well listen
Tristan while I disagree with you I
respect your right to have that opinion
what do you think of that
yes uh being disagreeing without being
disagreeable I think is the best way we
can put it Kristen thank you for the
call I appreciate it thank you all right
very important uh topics being being
broached today